this is not how I thought I would end
college high school where I'm from has
really been impacted by the virus we
expected something to happen soon but we
didn't know it would be this drastic so
quickly when my chancellor first sent
out an email telling us that UCSB is
going to promote I was shocked students
who were off campus during spring break
were essentially told to not come back
to campus and they were ordered to
either stay or go back to their
permanent address last week was my last
time in the facilities school is closed
students were instructed to evacuate and
join their families but I cannot because
I'm an international student and I
cannot leave because of travel bans as
an international student I do not have a
place to stay here and currently I'm in
a pretty sticky situation my visa was
rejected this week so I literally do not
have a place to go back right now and my
only choice is to stay here in America
and hopefully Georgetown I have chosen
to stay in Santa Cruz this is mainly
because if I am exposed to the virus and
I'm asymptomatic right now I don't want
to go back to my parents house and
accidentally expose my family when I
came home yesterday I had a lot of
paranoia around
I really just sat through a flight I
really just went through two of the
biggest airports and who knows what I
touched and I had this fear that okay if
I come home I can give anything to my
parents and I gonna give anything to my
older like relatives like my
grandparents being here in LA County
where the cases are soaring and doubling
and tripling with each day is really
heightening my fear I
may not be able to see my parents for an
extended period of time
due to their age they are in one of the
at-risk categories and I'm very afraid
that the next time I look at my phone
someone I know and love will be gone a
few of us are left here but everyone I
know and care about is halfway across
the globe so it is definitely very hard
to go through this on your own housing
is not a problem because I already live
off-campus but I believe it is a great
challenge to see all of my roommates and
classmates leave and run their families
while I cannot do that it is very very
hard to be productive and work online
when you're very worried for your family
who's in a very serious upgrade the
whole University is now pass/fail
mandatory you can't even opt in to take
a letter grade because for people who
are going home to family situations that
have to take care of a loved one who's
sick with this illness or you know
provide for their family because someone
might have lost a job they can't worry
about their grades right now no one
knows what's happening but in terms of
the professors and the universities
they're doing the best they can they
don't know how to cope just as much as
we don't know how to cope it is you know
really difficult to cater to all of the
needs of students online and I think a
lot of classes will struggle and we
really rely on the student to Professor
contact and relationship and I just
don't think that's really possible
online classes being moved online has
definitely lessen the quality of our
education like my science classes all of
our all of our labs have been just
cancelled what really stood out to me is
just how radically unprepared the
education system was for this switch I
know some of some professors in
humanities who didn't even use email
before all of this went down there are a
lot of students out there that are
really feeling lost right now and really
need a friend and they need someone to
talk to because
everything they knew was ripped away
from them and a set of emails a lot of
extracurriculars on campus have also
been totally eliminated I personally do
research in a lab and I am not allowed
to go on campus currently unless I have
things that I need to keep alive I'm an
athlete on the track team our entire
spring season got cancelled which is
really tough the organization that I'm
the president of all of our competitions
were cancelled which I understand why
for the safety of everyone I agree with
if they were canceled I cried a lot when
I found out that all of the work we had
put in for months and months and months
wasn't gonna happen this year I am in my
final semester of college I was supposed
to be abroad had that taken away from me
I'm supposed to be graduating walking in
May and there's a chance my commencement
ceremony could get canceled today
actually we just got an email that our
commencement ceremonies have been
cancelled it feels surreal like it's I'm
not even like sad or I know I know I
should be sad and disappointed and I I
guess I am to an extent but it doesn't
feel real to pick up you know leave
everything has been very it's been a lot
for me to process not getting the say
goodbye to friends in person has led to
a lot of really emotional FaceTime calls
and texting calls just thanking him for
being a friend for four years and I
should have said stuff before
coronavirus happened and I'm learning
that I go through periods where I feel
very angry about the situation and I
also go through periods where like I I'm
just in shock like I can't believe this
has happened so a high moment of this
experience is you know just a sense of
community and love and support going on
Facebook different pages have been
really uplifting with other students and
graduates being in the same position and
it's making me feel a lot better
they're just
a nice dose of humor and a place for all
all the students that are more or less
my age to come together in solidarity
and just laugh about things and provide
supportive things are more serious like
we're all in this together and the class
of 2020 will be remembered for sure with
all of this and we will be celebrated
one day or another even if it's months
after this pandemic it's terrible I may
not get to have a graduation ceremony I
may not get to see some of my friends
again but in the end it hopefully will
be because lives were saved
[Music]